welcome back to Las Vegas now the only
thing better than dessert is dessert
before dinner that's how the Girl Scouts
of Southern Nevada have been celebrating
for the past 13 years and how they
continue to spread the special message
of Girl Scouts and here to tell us more
about this annual event is Emmy Caston
and Chef yaren's son from the win we're
so happy to have you guys here thank you
for having us so this event is such a
staple in our community let's talk a
little bit about it tell us what
desserts before dinner really is oh my
gosh Jillian this is one of my favorite
events of the entire Gala season it's a
lot of people's very favorite event what
people do is we recruit some of the best
pastry chefs from all over the valley we
challenge them by giving them one
particular signature Girl Scout cookie
and we say make a dessert over out of
this and they make magic happen this is
truly beautiful and it's almost hard to
wrap your mind around the fact that this
actually comes from Girl Scout cookies
so Chef I'm going to bring you another
conversation here tell us what we have
in front of us okay so right now we have
a thin mint chocolate chip cookie in the
bottom and the layer of the brownie on
the top with the finishing with the
chocolate ganache and then some flour
and the Girl Scout logo on it everybody
loves the Brownie and chocolate chip
cookie so I kind of combined them
together and then we mix to make the
thin mint cookie from the Girl Scout so
here is my dessert it's a perfect
combination and for this event it's a
competition right among every Chef so
everybody who attends the event gets to
go around taste all of the different
desserts we have six chefs this year and
we also honor seven different women in
the community so people from all walks
of life everything from the Arts to law
to you name it different people who are
really inspiring and doing great things
and great role models for our Girl
Scouts yeah so it's about a little bit
more than the dessert even though the
dessert is the best part but anytime
that we have any of the Girl Scouts come
on their show here they are always so
well spoken and poised and just doing
incredible things in the community so we
love to support them but we're going to
put me to work that's right okay I mean
I'm gonna trade spots with you for a
second I always joke that we should
leave it to the professionals but I
trust you to teach me the art form so
what are we gonna do so I'm gonna pipe
the ganache on the side so we can have
our spoons but to put the thin mint
crumble in the middle and they're
finishing with the flour and then
garnish on it okay if you want to show
me one and then I'll follow sure always
yeah and really quickly while she's
working on this and then I'll try a hand
at it can people still get tickets for
the event there are tickets available
but very very few so I would encourage
all of your audience to get their
tickets ASAP to get on it okay because
you don't want to miss out on these
delicious desserts look how perfect
she's doing it okay this is the first
year it's happening at Wynn Resort an
encore Ballroom a beautiful backdrop for
this it is going to be a gorgeous event
and the first time we've done it in two
years because of the pandemic that's
going to be great that everyone will be
back together and enjoying these
delicious desserts look how perfect
she's making it okay can I try to put a
little I believe in you
I guess okay if I mess this up I just
should not be allowed to do anything
ever again okay you are allowed to eat
that so no matter what yes can we try a
bite of these once I make my my creation
here of course okay we're gonna put a
little flower on top and then this is
the garnish right the Girl Scout logo oh
and is this edible everything's edible
everything is edible okay how did I do
Chef
well done thank you okay I think we
should all grab one and cheers to this
special event let's see they're almost
too pretty to eat
I mean Chef thank you so much for being
here cheers to the Girl Scouts of
Southern Nevada be sure to go check out
the event what's the date again that's
happening August 26th August 26th at the
win you don't want to miss it cheers